[Musique]
ottawa et québec accorde une aide
financière de près de 5 millions de
dollars a loupé mission de boisbriand
pour augmenter et automatisée sa
production de jus et de ce mot tease
julie pautrat saunier et cofondatrice
président directeur général de look
bonsoir bonsoir alors votre entreprise
en est une justement c'est un bel
exemple d'économie circulaire qui combat
le gaspillage alimentaire s'est tenu
comme avoue fait madame pour est
rationnée
elle est en fait le modèle c56 qu'on
revalorise les aliments qui sont rejetés
par l'industrie alimentaire donc on
regarde les fruits et légumes qui seront
comme on les appelle parfaitement est
parfait donc elles sont déclassés pour
toutes sortes de raisons esthétiques qui
ont l'air transforme en jus pressé
ascquois ont aussi des guerres faites
avec du pain et rejeter du staff on avec
des huiles de schiste en bref nous on
veut montrer finalement à l'industrie
que la valeur économique dans ce qui
reste et parce que autrement il fait
payer pour se départir de sa matière là
et nous on les achète pour finalement se
transformer en vie et vous prenez à quel
endroit vos légumes et vos fruits qui
sont pressés chez vous
ça viennent d'un peu partout on a
commencé ma géothermie avec le
distributeur de fruits légumes
courchesne la rose parce que juste à eux
seuls on avait un surplus de 20 tonnes
par jour de fruits et légumes mais quand
on a commencé le projet on est reçu des
appels de partout même partout dans le
monde donc on revalorise maintenant des
aliments aussi de chaînes d'épicerie que
ce soit métro sobeys et on garde aussi
avec des producteurs directement donc
avec des fermiers qui vont rester
jusqu'à la fin donc ça provient
maintenant l'aude un petit peu partout à
travers le monde et vous quel est le
volume 2 de traitement de réaliser
revalorisation de produits que vous
faites là en ce moment vite autour de 45
à 50 tonnes par semaine puis avec là
mais on était limité ou non vous n'êtes
qu'à passer avec notre usine le ca fait
plusieurs contrats qu'on doit mettre de
côté parce que justement on utilisait
n'avait atteint sa capacité maximale
mail avec la nouvelle usine qu'on est
inaugurée aujourd'hui on va pouvoir et
valoriser leur facilement 5 x 7 quand il
au cours de la prochaine année alors
justement le coup de pouce quand même
important aujourd'hui des gouvernements
vous donne quoi ça va servir à quoi
exactement
oui c'est ça c'est des accidents sert
qu'on a reçue à sous forme de prêt pour
justement
acheter de nouveaux équipements à la
fine pointe de la technologie
automatisée nos processus pour augmenter
notre capacité donc l'objectif c'est
donc d'augmenter 2,5 fois notre capacit
production et surtout d'exporter nos
produits aux états unis donc nous en ce
moment on est nationalement travers le
canada mais on est déjà de la demande
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'était notre
première production officielle pour un
magasin aux états unis donc on commence
officiellement de déploiement à
l'international
c'est vraiment là que leurs droits aux
etats unis
c'est une chaîne nationale donc on se
concentre au départ beaucoup plus sur le
nord est des états unis mais cette
chaîne le et huile partout à travers le
pays donc on va dans 300 à plus de 320
go 381 magasins à travers les états unis
donc la californie jusqu'à jusqu'à new
york et vous viser l'europe et
l'australie également
exact oui notre vision avec luz est
vraiment d éventuellement répliquer le
modèle partout à travers le monde le
gaspillage alimentaire c'est un enjeu
mondial donc on veut aussi prochainement
exporter tous nos produits qu'on
fabrique ici mais éventuellement
répliquer le modèle donc bâtir des
usines en europe en australie on est
déjà en train de travailler partenaires
là-bas pour revaloriser leurs pertes à
eux parce qu'on veut pas nécessairement
tous revaloriser ici est ensuite
exportée on trouve que ça fait du sens
aussi de juste pouvoir développer le
même modèle avec les produits qui sont
jetés localement donc c'est sortir si
tout va devoir être adaptées à chaque
pays parce que le poulain store votre
production se fait des laurentides
essentiellement
exactement maintenant mais avant c'était
à anjou mais avec la nouvelle usine de
kooning inaugure aujourd'hui le savent a
été à partir de boisbriand vous avez
combien d'employés en iran d'une
soixantaine une soixantaine d'employés
et mais quand vous vous imaginez dans le
futur faire grandir cette entreprise là
vous imaginer quoi
nous depuis le jour 1 car on était juste
d'aller des mois dans un appartement et
les amplis donné travail et son attaque
salle à manger on a toujours dit qu'on
voulait être le leader mondial on
économise
donc c'est encore ça notre vision nous
on voit avoir des usines l'eau partout
dans le monde des milliers d'employés
donc on est vraiment une des grandes
ambitions parce que un grand problème
qui est le gaspillage alimentaire puis
on est sur une mission de le réduire
puis tellement d'accès d'aliments qui
s'enrichissent et le tiers des aliments
dans le monde qui sont rejetés donc on
en arrive à une place mais on réalise
qu'on pourra pas à nous seuls two
réduire complètement ce gaspillage a
donc on veut embarquer d'autres
entreprises dans ce projet là avec nous
donc notre vision c'est de voir aussi
créé des ingrédients pour d'autres
entreprises pour faciliter l'utilisation
des designers vous je lis poitras
saunier vous avez été formé en sciences
de l'environnement vous avez travaillé
en développement durable aussi dans de
grandes entreprises là aujourd'hui vous
avez ce projet que vous continuez de
développer puis on avait le rapport du
giec aujourd'hui qu'il montrait
clairement qu'on était extrêmement en
retard dans tous les investissements
vous avez l'impression clube jamais je
présume de faire partie de la solution
vraiment parce que le gaspillage
alimentaire c'est le troisième plus
grand émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
augmentent donc l'impact est énorme en
termes de changements climatiques puis
je pense aussi que en plus de l'impact
que nous on a concrètement c'est qu'on
inspire l'industrie a changé leur façon
de voir les choses donc de voir une
valeur économique dans leurs déchets de
voir qu'on peut repenser les modèles
d'affaires pour plutôt que faire de la
compétition vraiment faire la
collaboration pour que les rejets des
uns deviennent matières premières pour
les autres donc à partir du jour où
l'industrie collaborent ces grands
enjeux là je pense qu'on peut rapidement
avoir un impact positif
avoir un modèle justement qui est
exponentielle un impact toujours plus
grand je suis convaincu que votre
exemple et votre proposition vont
inspirer plusieurs en tout cas vous êtes
un bel exemple d'économie circulaire
julie poitras saunier confondre entre
ceux de loupe et pdg de look mission
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci beaucoup ça fait plaisir